kriminal hauptkommissar sebastian
fiedler ist ein gefragter experte für
geldwäscher die bundesregierung und das
europäische parlament suchen regelmäßig
seinem rad
unerfahren wählen dass hier mit
schmutzigem geld vor allem gold barren
gekauft wurden das problem
alles wurde bar bezahlt er ist
tatsächlich so dass also die bargeld
obergrenze die wir nicht haben in
deutschland ganz relevant dafür gewesen
ist weil ansonsten die einzahlungen für
den goldhändler eigentlich nicht so
erklärbar gewesen sind hätte ansonsten
eine vielzahl von unterschiedlichen
konstruktionen erklären müssen
dadurch dass es aber problemlos möglich
ist hunderttausende in bar auf ein konto
zu übergeben
kann so etwas natürlich auch nicht
auffallen das geht in deutschland
deshalb so gut weil man hier alles
bezahlen kann egal wie hoch der betrag
ist in anderen eu ländern ist das längst
anders in spanien liegt die obergrenze
bei 2500 euro
in italien war 1000 euro und in
griechenland bei nur 500 euro
ein sehr erfahrener kollege von mir
sagte vor einiger zeit mal etwas
humorvoll geht mir mal eine million euro
in bargeld und setzte mich an
irgendeiner straße er nannte als
beispiel die kö in düsseldorf raus und
ich brauche einen vormittag um das geld
umzusetzen in zum beispiel schmuck ohne
dass es irgendwo auffällt oder einer
meldung entsteht ist es wirklich so
einfach mit versteckter kamera machen
wir uns auf den weg zu
gebrauchtwagenhändlern barzahlung ist
egal nur bei über 10.000 euro muss ich
mich laut gesetz als käufer ausweisen
halten sich die händler auch daran meine
wahl fällt auf einen sportwagen schnell
komme ich mit dem händler ins gespräch
330 ps ledersitze 18.900 euro
kann ich bei euch bar bezahlen
ja aber überweisen die devils mein
ausweis braucht ihr aber nicht oder wenn
er jetzt darauf eingeht dann verstößt er
gegen das geldwäschegesetz nein ein
ausweis brauche ich nicht schreibe
einfach einen namen rheinländern hast
hier könnte ich also völlig anonym knapp
19.000 euro bargeld investieren
bei leichten länder ein porsche panamera
für 37.900 euro kann ich bezahlen oder
überweisen alles brauchen sie einen
perso für den kauf einen ausweis kann
ich auch hier mein geld loswerden ohne
nicht ausweisen zu müssen
nach keine ahnung du gibst mir deinen
namen einen anderen namen oder den namen
von einem kollegen
eine adresse für uns ist das wichtigste
das geld muss korrekt sein
das war's
ausweiskontrolle fehlanzeige hauptsache
das geld fließt sie finden eine
unterschiedliche güter händler aber den
seiner tagesordnung wie es in bar zu
bezahlen denken sie an
gebrauchtwagenhandel sie können auch
schmuck kaufen kunstgegenstände erwerben
wir haben mal über pferde optionen
diskutiert es gibt viele bereiche wo mit
durchaus sei jedenfalls fünfstelligen
summen an der tagesordnung operiert wird
in deutschland und das ist ein triviales
beispiel dafür dass es immer noch sehr
sehr leicht der schmutziges geld
irgendwie unterzubringen um es dann
anschließend weiter zu waschen
und genau so funktioniert die einfachste
form der geldwäsche in deutschland
geldwäscher schmuggeln ihr schmutziges
bargeld aus illegalen machenschaften
nach deutschland mit diesem geld kaufen
sie kostspielige waren wie zb goldbarren
kunstgegenstände autos oder teure uhren
durch den weiterverkauf dieser waren
wird aus dem schmutzigen geld sauberes
das ist möglich weil es in deutschland
keine so genannte bargeld obergrenze
gibt das heißt alles egal wie teuer kann
cash bezahlt werden erst ab 10.000 euro
muss man sich ausweisen
doch wer kontrolliert das eigentlich das
wollen wir später herausfinden
besonders lukrativ für geldwäscher sind
deutsche immobilien das
bundesfinanzministerium stuft das risiko
als hoch ein
allein den wert der berliner
wohnimmobilien schätzt das netzwerk
steuergerechtigkeit auf ungefähr 350
milliarden euro
doch wem gehören diese häuser eigentlich
genau das recherchiert christoph
trautvetter für das netzwerk
steuergerechtigkeit und wurde dazu
bereits als sachverständiger im
bundestag gehört wir treffen uns vor
einem gebäude gemietet vom finanzamt
berlin mitte die ergaben laut
trautvetter war diese immobilie bis ende
letzten jahres im besitz einer
libanesischen
vermögensverwaltungsgesellschaft wenn
man sich die eigentums strukturen dieser
vermögensverwaltung libanon anguckt
landet man bei gesellschaften aus dem
aus panama aus dem british virgin
islands verwaltet von einer
anwaltskanzlei massak fonseka die in
2016 in den panama papers dafür berühmt
geworden ist dass sie leuten aus der
reichen leuten aus der ganzen welt dabei
hilft anonym
illegale gelder um den globus zu
verschieben
der vertrag zwischen der libanesischen
vermögen
verwaltungsgesellschaft und der kanzlei
im mossad von tecart legt zdfzoom vor
das finanzamt berlin mit der tiergarten
zahl knapp 13.000 euro miete im monat
seit anfang dieses jahres fließen diese
steuergelder nach luxemburg eine dort
angesiedelte vor konstruktion hat die
immobilie gekauft wer sich dahinter
verbirgt und tatsächlich die
mieteinnahmen kassiert bleibt im
verborgenen
[Musik]
die suche nach anonymem
immobilieneigentümern führt christoph
trautvetter immer wieder in das berlin
eigentlich sollten hier die eigentümer
verzeichnet sein
seit 2017 gibt es in deutschland ein so
genanntes transparenz register
das soll dazu dienen dass man die so
genannten wirtschaftlich berechtigten
also den tatsächlichen eigentümer einer
immobilie feststellen kann
doch bei seinen untersuchungen wurde
christoph trautvetter häufig enttäuscht
dass transparenz register ist leer das
transparenz register ist tatsächlich in
diesem fall und in vielen fällen das
haben wir auch recherchiert also in
knapp 80 von 100 fällen leer und
deswegen waffen eingetragen wird nur wer
mehr als 25 prozent an einer immobilie
besitzt sind also vier personen oder
mehr beteiligt wird keiner eingetragen
und das transparenz register bleibt leer
schlupflöcher für anonyme
immobiliengeschäfte
fest steht jeder der in deutschland eine
immobilie erwerben oder verkaufen möchte
egal ob legal oder illegal muss den
vertrag von einem notar beglaubigen
lassen müsste nicht spätestens hier
verdacht geschöpft werden wenn
geldwäsche im spiel ist wir treffen die
berliner notaren dörte zimmermann
tauchen bei ihr tatsächlich klienten mit
dem berühmten geldkoffer auf es gibt
kein fahrgeschäft a
es gibt hier niemanden der hier mit dem
koffer kommt und dann der notarberuf
oder hinterher wird der koffer übergeben
was wir natürlich nicht wissen ob nicht
tatsächlich bargeld fließt wenn die dann
sich treffen um den kaufpreis zu
bezahlen das ist eben nicht
auszuschließen weil die notarin eine
entscheidende rolle zukommt hat der
gesetzgeber so zu sogenannten melde
verpflichteten erklärt das heißt
auffälligkeiten die auf geldwäsche
hindeuten musste zum anmelden diese
verpflichtung wurde im oktober letzten
jahres noch einmal verschärft weil 2009
10 insgesamt nur 17 verdachtsmeldungen
von allen deutschen notaren abgegeben
wurden ich melde wahrscheinlich im
hauptteil sachverhalte wo eben erhöhter
kaufpreis der die person passt nicht zu
dem geschäft die geben mir keine
auskünfte
auch freunde nicht sagen wer hinter uns
steht das alles treuhand nur solche
situation
das würde ich melden wir wollen wissen
wie so eine geldwäsche verdachtsmeldung
aussieht und wo sie lernen
es läuft alles online wo ich sage ich
muss jetzt melden und dann entscheidend
ist hier unten eigentlich die kunde dann
auch das auch noch meine hilfe dass ich
hier angeben kann was was die gründe für
die meldung sind das berichtet sich aber
auch an alle verpflichteten nicht nur
notare sind zur geldwäsche
verdachtsmeldungen verpflichtet sondern
unter anderem auch banken
immobilienmakler steuerberater und güter
händler wie zum beispiel die
gebrauchtwagenverkäufer bei denen ich
schon war
im kampf gegen geldwäsche spielen all
diese verpflichteten eine schlüsselrolle
denn nur wenn sie einen verdacht melden
kann überhaupt erst ermittelt werden und
hier landen die geldwäsche
verdachtsmeldungen bei der financial
intelligence unit kurz f b jugend
die behörde war früher beim
bundeskriminalamt angesiedelt sei 2017
untersteht die fau der generaldirektion
und damit dem bundesfinanzministerium
von olaf scholz hat eine filterfunktion
sie soll geldwäscheverdachts meldungen
entgegen nehmen bewerten und
gegebenenfalls an die
strafverfolgungsbehörden weiterleiten
doch es scheint eklatante missstände
innerhalb der behörde zu geben
uns wird ein geheimer bericht des
bundesrechnungshofs zugespielt auf 25
seiten wird die arbeit der fh wien
genauer untersucht die fau kann auf
regionale polizeidaten der
länderpolizeien nicht elektronisch zu
greifen und weiter die fau kann auch auf
einen großteil wichtiger steuerdaten
nicht elektronisch zu greifen das fazit
des berichtes ist vernichtend
die fau kann damit die in sie gesetzten
erwartungen nur unzureichend erfüllen
es besteht vor allem die gefahr dass die
fh sachverhalte mit bezug zur geldwäsche
oder terrorismusfinanzierung nicht
erkennt und ihren gesetzlichen auftrag
insbesondere ihrer filterfunktion nicht
gerecht wird
in berlin nicht verabredet mit markus
herbrand er ist mitglied im
finanzausschuss des bundestages und
kritisiert die eingeschränkten
zugriffsrechten der f k you seit jahren
da der bundesrechnungshof bestätigt
eigentlich nur das was einige politiker
unter anderem auch ich in den letzten
jahren immer wieder mal zur sprache
gebracht haben das einfach die
geldwäschebekämpfung in deutschland
nicht funktionieren funktioniert der eu
fehlt nicht nur der zugriff auf
entscheidende daten
sie leitet die verdachtsfälle auch noch
verspätet weiter so der vorwurf
markus herbrand konfrontierte die
bundesregierung mit den beschwerden aus
den strafverfolgungsbehörden
in der ebenfalls als verschlusssache
gekennzeichneten antwort der
bundesregierung vom januar 2020 räumt
die fau die versäumnisse zum teil 1
spricht von arbeits fehlern im
einzelfall und begründet es mitunter so
zum zeitpunkt des jeweiligen meldung
eingangs war nur ein empfang von
verdachtsmeldungen per fax bei der eu
möglich die gangster lachen sich kaputt
darüber was sie hier in deutschland
machen können das kann ja nicht sein uns
kann es als rechtsstaat nicht egal sein
das inkriminierte gelder über
deutschland wieder in den geldkreislauf
geraten
unzureichender datenzugriff mangelhafte
prüfberichte und verspätet
weitergeleitete meldungen dazu wollen
wir christoph schulte den leiter der
behörde fragen was sagt er zum fazit des
bundesrechnungshofs dass die eu ihren
gesetzlichen auftrag nicht erfüllen
könne
also diese einschätzung teile ich so
nicht nach meiner einschätzung ist es in
dieser erstmalig gelungen
an einer zentralen stelle des bundes
vorhandene erkenntnisse zusammenzuführen
und in einer gesamtschau zu bringen
aus kreisen der strafverfolgungsbehörden
hierbei immer wieder den vorwurf die
berichte die wir von der eu bekommen
sind qualitativ nicht gut nicht
ausreichend manche sagen sogar wir
fangen sowieso immer wieder von vorne an
mit ermittlungen weil wir damit also
bekommen nichts anfangen können sind
ihre berichte zu schlecht also man
sollte sich berechtigte kritik
verschließen und da wird es sicherlich
den ein oder anderen punkt geben an dem
auch unsere berichte noch in teilen
vielleicht zu kurz greifen in teilen
vielleicht zu weit geht
wir konfrontieren dass verantwortliche
bundesfinanzministerium mit den
vorwürfen des bundesrechnungshofes und
den ergebnissen unserer recherche ein
interview gibt uns olaf scholz nicht
schriftlich heißt es die eu kann mit den
ihr zur verfügung stehenden daten
zugriffsrechten ihren gesetzlichen
auftrag aus dem geldwäschegesetz in
vollem umfang erfüllen
zum datenaustausch heißt es hinsichtlich
der polizeidaten der länder ist zu
beachten dass diese der datenhoheit der
länder unterliegen
ein zugriff der fau setzt daher die
zustimmung der länder voraus
[Musik]
hinsichtlich bestimmter steuerlicher
grunddaten wird ein verbesserter
automatisierter zugriff der eu
angestrebt und schließlich unbeschadet
dessen prüft das bundesministerium der
finanzen laufend weitere maßnahmen um
die operative analyse der ever you noch
effektiver zu machen
uns erreicht ein weiterer geheimer
prüfbericht des bundesrechnungshofs zum
thema geldwäsche
darin geht es um die aufsicht durch die
bundesländer
deren aufgabe ist es die melde
verpflichteten im sogenannten nicht
finanzsektor zu kontrollieren
also immobilienmakler notare und alle
güter händlern
aus dem bericht geht hervor dass für
diese kontrollen kaum personal
eingesetzt wird
bei dieser kontrolle quote müsste ein
verpflichteter durchschnittlich nur
höchstens alle 200 jahre mit einer vor
ort prüfung rechnen dass deshalb die
verpflichteten wie zb unsere
gebrauchtwagenhändler manchmal mit den
vorschriften nicht so genau nehmen
wundert andreas frank überhaupt nicht
als experte in sachen geldwäsche war er
schon mehrmals als sachverständiger im
bundestag und im europarat tätig seine
meinung warum deutschland nach wie vor
ein paradies für geldwäscher ist
deutschland diesen rechtsstaat das heißt
bei uns sind die hürden für
strafverfolgung für die gerichte sehr
hoch das schätzen die geldwäsche dann
haben wir in deutschland relativ liquide
märkte
ich glaub 250 milliarden im jahr umsatz
immobilienmarkt der fall eine
transaktion von 400 millionen nicht
preistreibend auf oder sonst irgendetwas
und last not least deutschland ist ein
sehr politisch stabiles land
bei uns wird eigentum geschützt also
spricht alles für deutschland nachdem
auch die die gesetze so rasch umgesetzt
werden alles für deutschland und das
geld zu waschen gehen andere länder
europas konsequenter gegen geldwäsche
vor als deutschland
das wollen wir herausfinden und fahren
nach rom ausgerechnet das land der mafia
geld heute vielen als vorbild im kampf
gegen geldwäsche italien erfuhr leidvoll
was es bedeutet wenn die organisierte
kriminalität dem start unterwandert
wir sind mit der senatorin laura
garavini verabredet sie hat neben der
italienischen auch die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft
seit jahren kämpft sie dafür dass auch
in deutschland schärfer gegen die
organisierte kriminalität vorgegangen
wird
nach den mafia-morden in duisburg 2007
gründete sie den verein mafia nein danke
die mafia hat ein großes problem und
zwar geld zu waschen
die mafia geht nach deutschland gerade
öfter um geld zu waschen
in deutschland ist beispielsweise die
bargeld obergrenze immer noch nicht
eingeführt worden
in italien beispielsweise darf man nicht
waren kaufen
die mehr als 1000 euro kosten mit
bargeld
damit das geld einfach verfolgt werden
kann
das war eine der der lehre des richters
falcone also die mafia zu bekämpfen
indem man das geld verfolgt der richter
giovanni falcone bezahlt den kampf gegen
die mafia mit seinem leben 1992 wird er
durch einen bombenanschlag getötet nur
wenige wochen später stirbt auch sein
mitstreiter paolo borsellino bei einem
sprengstoffanschlag auf sein fahrzeug
italien musste ja anfang der neunziger
jahre schmerzhaft erfahren was es
bedeutet wenn die mafia zu viel macht
ein nimmt die demokratie aushöhlt was
waren die lehren daraus
auf grund der empörung bei der
bevölkerung sind dann gesetze entstanden
die einen großen beitrag geleistet haben
bei der bekämpfung der organisierten
kriminalität beispielsweise das gesetz
zur vermögensabschöpfung und sorge weiß
last umkehren das bedeutet ist in
italien zum beispiel ein wegen
geldwäsche verdächtigt avio so mit einem
teuren sportwagen unterwegs dann muss er
haben das als in deutschland gegenüber
den ermittlern beweisen dass er diesen
erworben hat sonst wird das auto
beschlagnahmt
2019 würden so über 800 millionen euro
durch den staat abgeschöpft und an
gemeinnützige organisationen verteilt
das hat eben die die erfahrung gezeigt
in italien
die mafiosi also man trifft ihnen mehr
indem man ihnen die güter wegnimmt als
wenn man sie beispielsweise ins
gefängnis schickt kriminelle rechnen
eigentlich damit irgendwann im gefängnis
zu sitzen
aber wenn man ihnen eben ihren reichtum
wegnimmt ihren kriminellen reichtum
wegnimmt
das kränkt sie nicht nur sondern es
nimmt ihnen einfach ihre macht weg es
war so als ob man ihnen die luftröhre
kappen wurde ein modell auch für
deutschland seit knapp drei jahren gibt
es auch bei uns einen neuen paragraphen
zur vermögensabschöpfung von kriminellen
hier in berlin wurde er zum ersten mal
in einem spektakulären fall angewendet
bei ermittlungen gegen mitglieder des
berüchtigten remo clans der wegen
drogenhandels und raubüberfällen immer
wieder für schlagzeilen sorgt gerät ein
familienmitglied besonders ins visier
er kaufte teure immobilien bezieht aber
gleichzeitig arbeitslosengeld vom staat
wegen verdacht auf geldwäsche werden 77
immobilien im wert von knapp zehn
millionen euro vorläufig beschlagnahmt
[Musik]
noch ist nicht sicher ob in diesem fall
geldwäsche nachgewiesen werden kann
trotzdem werden die immobilien
wahrscheinlich in staatlicher hand
bleiben
eine gesetzesänderung macht das möglich
wenn aber dann genügend hinweise
vorliegen dass dieser
vermögensgegenstand illegal erworben
wurde aus einer straftat herrührt endet
der 76 die möglichkeit mehr einen so
genannten selbständigen einziges
verfahren diesen vermögensgegenstand
einzuziehen
das schwert der strafverfolgung ist
durch den paragrafen schärfer geworden
denn jetzt müssen kriminelle damit
rechnen ihre illegal erworbenen
vermögenswerte auch dann zu verlieren
denn der tatbestand der geldwäsche nicht
nachgewiesen werden kann und das ist ein
deutlicher fortschritt im vergleich zur
früheren rechtslage und was ich da auch
wirklich sagen möchte auch im hinblick
auf die gerechtigkeit eine wesentliche
säule auch um effektiv inkriminierte
vermögen einzuziehen und kriminalität zu
bekämpfen damit zumindest das was
illegal erlangt wurde auch wieder
eingezogen werden kann
die vereinfachte vermögensabschöpfung
bei kriminellen ist ein erster schritt
um geldwäsche in deutschland zu
bekämpfen
doch das reicht nicht die eu muss
schneller auf alle wichtigen polizei und
steuer daten zugreifen können
außerdem müssten die bundesländer mehr
personal einsetzen um die melde
verpflichteten zu überprüfen
was fehlt ist eine bargeld obergrenze
wie sie die eu schon seit jahren fordert
nur dann kann sichergestellt werden dass
deutschland nicht weiter im paradies für
geldwäscher ist
[Musik]